when you say what amendment to the
Constitution the one that of course
flashed into my mind maybe Sean so
obvious was the one that has been
pending ever since I think was first
introduced back in the early in the 20th
century they so-called Equal Rights
Amendment for women but that really
shouldn't have been necessary because
the Fourteenth Amendment which was added
after the Civil War already granted
equality and all the privileges and
immunities of citizenship to all persons
women are persons why do we need our own
constitutional right in fact I would say
we didn't even really need the Bill of
Rights or the Fourteenth Amendment I
mean those were sort of making like
crystal clear what had already been
crystal clear from the beginning and so
it's kind of who's enforcing it rather
than what the language is